es imposible hablar de política en eeuu
sin mencionar a esos lobbies que
presionan a los políticos para que
saquen leyes que les beneficien sin
embargo fuera de este país los lobbies
son como los fans de justin bieber todo
el mundo sabe que existen pero nadie los
ha visto de hecho en españa es muy raro
ver al representante de algún lobby
salir por algún medio de comunicación
sin embargo son tan poderosos los
lobbies en eeuu como nos los pintan las
series de televisión o realmente es en
europa y en latinoamérica donde tienen
más poder precisamente porque nadie los
conoce hoy vamos a contestar a esa
pregunta pero primero vamos a daros un
poquito de perspectiva histórica
a los lobbies son tan antiguos como la
política misma en la edad media las
clases profesionales se agrupaban en
torno a gremios para tener más poder de
influencia frente a los reyes en el
norte de europa tenemos el caso de la
liga hanseática que fue el primer caso
de asociación transnacional de
comerciantes los miembros de la falsa
eran mercaderes alemanes suecos
holandeses o incluso estonio
y en su momento de máximo poder
consiguieron que el rey de dinamarca les
concediera el monopolio de todo el
comercio de escandinavia pero el lobby
tal y como lo conocemos hoy en día nace
con la democracia en eeuu y por qué pues
porque de repente el gobierno estaba
obligado a escuchar al pueblo es más en
la constitución estadounidense se
reconoce por primera vez el llamado
derecho de petición que significa que
cualquier ciudadano puede exigir
información al parlamento e incluso
sugerir cambios y compensaciones legales
es decir que todos los ciudadanos tienen
derecho a influir en la toma de
decisiones políticas es más el término
login en inglés significa sala de espera
y viene de la época del presidente
ulises ese gran este señor era un
fumador empedernido al que su mujer le
prohibía terminantemente encender puros
en la casa blanca así que cada vez que
quería fumar se tenía que ir a la sala
de espera y todos los que querían hablar
con él estaban ahí ya esperándole
dispuestos a invitarle a una copita de
brandy
bueno poco a poco las empresas pero
también los sindicatos se dieron cuenta
de que merecía la pena invertir un
poquito de dinero en tener a
profesionales a tiempo completo
contratados para estar en washington y
relacionarse con los políticos así es
como nació todo un sector económico que
hoy en día da trabajo solo en esta
ciudad a más de diez mil personas
lo vi en eeuu casi todo el trabajo de un
lobbista consiste en informar a los
políticos sobre temas concretos pensante
un diputado que tenga que sacar una
nueva regulación para las farmacias no
tiene por qué saber nada sobre el sector
farmacéutico y sobre la medicina y ahí
es cuando llega por ejemplo el
representante de facer y le expone su
punto de vista y después llega el del
sindicato de médicos y le da otra
perspectiva alternativa porque ojo no os
olvidéis de que hay muchísimos lobbies
en cada sector y muchos de ellos pueden
tener puntos de vista totalmente
antagónicos
es decir que el lobby tiene también su
parte buena cuál es el problema pues que
en muchos casos los lobbistas quieren
sobornar a los políticos el broma
avramov pago varios viajes a un
congresista incluido una escocia y le
invitaba a su propio restaurante el
signature donde todas las bebidas las
pagaba la casa y lo peor es que este
tipo de políticas no son para nada
excepcionales with probable llegamos a
tener una fuerte influencia en alrededor
de 100 políticos en su momento
por eso en el año 1992 el congreso
americano sacó la primera ley de
transparencia de logs por fin una ley
prohibía expresamente que un político
aceptara regalos o viajes pagados pero
lo más importante fue la creación de un
registro obligatorio de lobbistas es
decir que cualquiera que quiera influir
en un político tiene que dar su nombre
es decir para quién trabaja qué
intereses representa y cuáles son sus
cometidos y no sólo eso además los
políticos están obligados a informar de
las reuniones que mantienen con cada
persona
precisamente por eso es tan fácil hablar
de lobbies en eeuu los lobbistas salen
por la televisión cualquiera puede ver
para quién trabajan cuánto dinero ganan
y cuánto dinero se gastan de hecho en la
descripción os he dejado un par de links
muy interesantes donde lo podéis
consultar sin embargo esto no evita que
ocurran cosas como estos no les deja la
casa blanca para trabajar como lobbista
para johnson and johnson efectivamente a
falta de sobornos que mejor que ofrecer
salarios millonarios a cambio de firmar
una ley por eso desde el año 2007 cada
vez que un político en eeuu deja su
cargo tiene que pasar como mínimo un año
en lo que llaman el frigorífico antes de
poder trabajar para un lobby por
supuesto que estas leyes no son la
panacea y no pueden evitar que ocurran
casos de corrupción pero por lo que
vamos a ver ahora eeuu tiene una ley
bastante mejor que la que vemos en otros
países
cómo se regulan los lobbies en el resto
del mundo el registro obligatorio de
lobbista se ha convertido en una
tradición en todos los países
angloparlantes reino unido canadá
australia en todos estos sitios hay un
registro público que se puede consultar
por internet sin embargo en el resto del
mundo apenas están controlados por
ejemplo colombia o españa ni siquiera
tienen un registro y en la unión europea
este censo es voluntario es decir que si
un político quiere mantener una reunión
en secreto puede hacerlo y nadie puede
echarle nada en cara y por eso es muy
fácil pensar que europa está libre de
lobbies o que solo nos afectan aquellos
que defienden el bien común pero el bien
común para ti es una cosa pero cuando te
digan que por vivir en común tienes que
quedarte sin comer y sin trabajar tú y
tus cuatro hijos de tu mujer tu concepto
de visión común cambia sin embargo las
cifras están ahí como os decía antes en
washington hay más de 10000 lobbistas
registrados en bruselas la estimación
más baja dice que hay 15.000 pero
algunas fundaciones aseguran que hay más
de 30.000 no vistas es decir 3
a veces más que en eeuu y esta sala han
venido los los productores los
agricultores de tabaco canarios a
decirnos que son tres mil familias que
ojo lo que legislamos los agricultores
la philips morris y os preguntaréis pero
realmente tienen tanto poder los lobbies
en europa bueno pues juzgan por vosotros
mismos la federación europea de editores
es uno de los grupos de presión más
antiguos de toda europa fue fundado en
el año 1967 y engloba a los principales
periódicos de la unión europea no
podemos conocer su presupuesto económico
pero sí se puede ver que han tenido en
los últimos dos años más de veinte
reuniones con los políticos europeos
y digo reuniones oficiales porque como
no están obligados a reportar es posible
que hayan tenido otras secretas
su principal reclamación actualmente es
que se saque una ley que obligue a
google a pagar una tasa especial por
poner links de sus noticias en el
buscador lo que se conoce como la tasa
google os parecerá una tontería pero en
españa y alemania ya lo han conseguido y
en europa parece que no anda muy bien
la comisión europea ha presentado un
plan para obligar a las compañías de
internet a pagar por enlazar a noticias
online ojo que no estoy diciendo que
ésta sea corrupción ni siquiera estoy
diciendo que la comisión europea que
sería como el gobierno de europa esté
sacando esta ley al dictado de los
lobbies de los editores es más estoy
seguro de que han tenido en cuenta
varios puntos de vista de hecho pronto
vamos a sacar otro vídeo hablando de
como las empresas de estilo google están
empezando a invertir seriamente en
lobbies pero lo que está claro es que
aquí ha habido una influencia clara del
lobby de los editores no sabemos si
mucha o poca pero algo hábitos
y lo que quería demostraros en el vídeo
de hoy es que el pena venado en lo mismo
está presente en todo el mundo la
diferencia es que en eeuu por lo menos
está regulado y la pregunta es creéis
que en europa y en latinoamérica
tendríamos que poner regulaciones a los
lobbies al estilo de las que hay en eeuu
seguís pensando que la democracia
estadounidense está controlada por los
lobbies mientras que vuestro país está
libre de pecado
podéis dejarme vuestra opinión en los
comentarios personalmente me parece una
pena que los medios de comunicación
apenas hablen de los lobbies y por eso
en visual político nos gusta tratar
estos temas de vez en cuando si os
interesa saber más sobre los lobbies no
olvidéis en suscribiros al canal y en
seguirnos en nuestras redes sociales
pero no os vayáis todavía que tengo una
cosa muy importante que deciros tenéis
un grupo de rock alguno de nuestros
amigos toca en una banda pues mandarnos
vuestras canciones a esta dirección de
correo electrónico si vuestro estilo
encaja con los temas que tratamos en el
canal utilizaremos nuestra música en
nuestros vídeos por supuesto os
citaremos y os daremos toda la difusión
que nos sea posible y ahora sí si os ha
gustado este vídeo
y nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo y
hasta pronto